hello there
reject nation we're gonna watch the
irishman today I am so excited for this
movie
that's so excited so excited that it's
5:50 in the morning we're gonna watch
this trailer and game once about time in
Hollywood and the irishman most
anticipated movies of the year my
brother's birthday is today so I wanted
to say I wanted to say that Jabby
kawaii happy birthday
now you son of a [ __ ] you alright
that's it mm-hmm
Joe Pesci I might write to you about him
I'm gonna put him on the phone let it go
okay oh yes how are you Frank this is
Jimmy offer me this weekend glad to meet
you too even if it's over the phone
my friends Peter I hear you thank you
only three people in the world have one
of these only one of them is Irish might
be demonstrating to show appreciation I
see if succeed
oh you can't miss the big picture
[Music]
anybody could here's a date
you want to be a part of this
would you like to be a part of this
history yes I would whatever you need me
to do I'm available
he likes it that's a damn good the aging
that's serious
[Music]
let's just watch it three more times
easily that's a movie I'm going to the
theaters to watch when it has its
limited release man oh that looks great
that's exactly what I wanted it to be I
mean we know that we didn't get we're
like it's the scenes with like Pacino
and De Niro but you know you're gonna
get that in the movie here yeah yeah
yeah you know there's probably gonna be
some kind of new iconic moment wall be
quoting you know Joe Pesci or something
I'm so excited for this for a variety of
reasons before there was I was even a
teenager I was starting my own Pacino De
Niro marathon so I would watch like a
Pacino movie DeNiro movie but you know
DeNiro movie ought to culminate to the
movie heat you know I was before
Righteous Kill
so I just loved doing that of course
most of those I'm not most but a lot of
those classic De Niro films were
directed by Martin Scorsese I even
realized that at a young age that like
that's too bad Pacino has never actually
been yeah it says it's cool to get the
role of Jimmy Hoffa which is like which
is a glass of character to play
well yeah this is like a hugely infamous
story and it's been a mystery ever since
the 70s like Jimmy Hoffa's death and so
you had to go over not only that period
of time but also his mob ties and stuff
like is perfect Scorsese territory
because not only is it this huge crime
legend almost but it's also the most
legendary crime director coming to do
this yes so not only is it exciting to
get all these titans of crime cinema
together but also for a story like this
is really exciting too well I heard that
they had to ask Joe Pesci like 50 times
or something like that I don't want to
do it I'm too busy sleeping he was
retired and he and it's cool how heavily
featured he is in this trailer like it's
not just like oh we want you for a scene
please do it it's clearly a main
character here which just brings you
back to like the Goodfellas casino days
where there's usually like three main
characters and he's one of those three
main characters you know well he's
playing like a boss in this movie from
what I understand and weirdly enough
like it's exciting just to get the
prospect of Pesci
DeNiro and a Scorcese flick but weirdly
watching Joe Pesci back got me super
excited all well a big part of the this
Scorsese collaborations you know like
Raging Bull Casino Goodfellas and I and
I think they work together also Once
Upon a Time in America I want to say and
also the Good Shepherd which DeNiro
directed the Pesci De Niro collaboration
is also a classic duo as well and so
getting that back it was just a Niro in
a movie helmed by Scorsese which we
haven't had in so long oh yeah I feel
like we're gonna see didn't someone
deniro's best work that we've seen a
very long time he looks like the most
respectable thing yeah a long long long
time Pacino does look great in the film
I heard this movie owned is really cost
like a hundred million but after with
post-production like that awesome
de-aging you see a hundred seventy-five
million dollars I don't know how they
plan on making their money back I don't
know what the hell to make money back
for this but people are gonna tune in
for this movie oh yeah like you see from
the time we downloaded this trailer
YouTube's report on this forty minutes
ago forty five thousand views which
means in YouTube numbers it's probably
like seventy to eighty thousand so you
know this is gonna be a real this this
is gonna be like uh like an event film
for Netflix yeah I mean this seemed I
mean they've been producing caliber
movies for a little while now but this
seems like another step up in terms of
you know really legitimate cinema I
can't imagine this movie going bad I
just can't like this trailer literally
was everything I wanted it to be that
harkens back to other sources a classic
films also you know touching on like
around the JFK period time as well the
hopper characters been explored a lot in
that band mystery so to have this novel
be adapted and I think is a really cool
prospect but the guy who wrote this it's
cool they gave him credit Steve Zaillian
he wrote Schindler's List clear and
present danger he's written some
not-so-great movies too but it did write
American Gangster he co-wrote Moneyball
but he also did gangs in New York which
is another Scorsese hashim project and
he did the script for awakening split of
course had Robert De Niro in it he's
getting his composure
back from wolf of wallstreet for this
movie and shutter island'
I forget that person's name but then
also the cinematographer of silence and
the wife and the wolf of wallstreet so
these are people who has made great
movies with and of course his a
consistent editor I always want to say
Felmy shoe-shiner shoot shoot maker as I
always imagined her name I feel like the
only thing this movie is missing now is
like Dustin Hoffman and Christopher
Walken and gene Hackman and what Liotta
word is really ordered like a dick or
something he's never everything like a
Scorsese film you got the least amount
of attention right now he's doing like
you know liquor and anti-smoking
commercials yes you know he's got Chanti
got he's got to nail down got that
pharmaceutical money
I mean Harvey Keitel supposed to be in
this too which is also a thing I'm very
much excited for you don't have to like
mean streets and taxi drivers well yeah
yeah yeah you know in all those West
Anderson movies Ray Romano's in this
yeah yeah and I'm always excited when
when you know Martin Scorsese mixes
things up like then adds you know
comedians yeah things you know like his
his cast it like these one of those
filmmakers were just every choice winds
up to be at least something interesting
even if you don't always agree with it
and just to look at the imagery from
this trailer just gets you so excited
it's like it's been a long time I feel
like since I've seen a crime movie of
like the Scorsese variety I've seen a
lot of stuff that wants to be like it
but there's something different one can
do what he does yeah yeah those kinds of
shots that convey such gravitas like all
those like slow-motion moments and stuff
and all these like patience of just
people talking and there's like I'm out
of the 300 scenes in this movie it's a
lot of scenes be well worthy yeah De
Niro Pacino had a few minutes of screen
time I think the reporter runtime was 10
minutes and he and then they did
Righteous Kill together which was just
such a disappointment cuz that was
supposed to be that what we're like oh
they get so much great yeah you're like
an hour of screen time and the idea now
that you have Pacino and De Niro who are
gonna share a lot more screen time
together under the direction
like yeah I don't need a trailer tow it
you could have just shown like a bunch
of images of them and I would have been
totally content read the IMDB page
seriously I would have been like just
perfectly fine going down that route I
might be tired of [ __ ] right now
but hey but Marty I'm so you'll wake up
from your audio I gotta work on my
mobster impressions alright guys well
are you excited for the Irishman leave
your comments down below you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification will get notified whenever
we've got a YouTube video I wanted to
give a page of the day shots a man named
Jay and Valente Jay and we've been
talking recently and I know you've been
going through a rather rough patch I
just want you to know that it only gets
worse from here imagine the worst case
scenario really feel it and that's where
you're gonna get yeah that's what you
deserve downhill downhill like Henry
Hill but on a serious note I'm sorry for
and say I'm sorry for everything that
you be going through lately and just
know that John and I both really care
and really do love you amigo you've
meant the world to us over the course of
us having a patreon page and even before
that you've been such a big supporter
even though you're going through a hard
time the amount of positive energy of
thrown our away there's literally not
enough words there's no words I could
use to describe just how overwhelming
it's been I want you to know that we
have received your love and want to give
something I love back so thank you for
everything dude
you're the best you're and I hope
everything turns out well if not I hope
it turns out the worst